last time on dragon ball z
in many of these homes i was told i had
[Applause]
[Music]
hahahahahahahahahahaha
and now the conclusion
new mexico does um
so
my my natural mother was
uh she so much didn't want to be part
of the racism
that she pushed herself to go
outside of it and go
ha ha look what i'm doing
[ __ ] you you know what i'm gonna start
telling my truth
and i'm gonna start looking at the truth
of it and i'm gonna start telling the
world
and the universe that's doing things
against fellow
man woman child
animal plant that cannot live
speak or defend itself
[Music]
i will do what i can
but i have these fears these deep
deep-seated
entrenched hammered in
[ __ ] fears beaten into me fears
so i'm asking my friends for support
and sharing love sharing with the world
peace
and love and joy
when i can't hold my sword i'm asking
you to help me
when i can't open my eyes i'm asking you
to help me see
when it comes time to spread the truth
and uncover
darkness
i'm asking you to help me and support me
i'm going to tell you something right
now i'm gonna be spitting
the truth from this day forward
if you think it's a lie
i don't care if it's your opinion
i don't give a [ __ ]
but if you can prove to me factually and
show me hard evidence that what i
say is untrue i will gladly remove your
name
or change it but i will not remove
my name or change my truth from this day
forward
if you are a friend of mine you will
stand with me
jesus christ if you are not jesus christ
[ __ ] you oh [ __ ] this is the moment just
say right now that i'm a proud supporter
of eight
one and a half this is the origin this
is the origin
you want me to say words against them it
will not happen
i love the red and white
i have the power of the wings of angels
and we're in this together
even if i have to work separately from
the privacy
of my own home because i'm scared
i love you all and i wish for you peace
love and joy
in the name of my god
i am a follower of jesus christ
and his teaching and a lover of the
pagan traditions
my name is tracy craig aka
middle i speak for the trees
and the bees and the fleas
and as john wayne i wear the black
for the suffrage of my little man
peace love joy
honor respect
for the eight one oops
for the eight one
much love loyalty honor and respect
i love the freedom of my country
but i want us all to be one nation one
heart one world
by marley man one heart
we witnessed this we we witnessed the
snap
we witnessed the
we witness the snap
if somebody wants uh fate or
bali or any one of you want to recut
this as a horror film
that would be amazing because i really
do think you could recut this as a
[ __ ] terrifying horror film
yes horrifying alice report i i agree it
gets work we're not even done yet
it gets worse but i we just pinpointed
the origin
dick i'm kidding what do you think now
what do you think now
this is the link to the long cut
you could just search for tracy gregg g
r
e i g
this being called of god thing
seems a bit weird to me
um and also do you think that this
camera makes
my lazy eye stand out more
or less probably more
you know what i don't care i like it
it makes me
went out to check my mail and i got a
glimpse of the first quarter moon
sure is pretty in the middle
you ever just feel like bursting into
song hi
i'm tracy g and i do it a lot and this
morning
this is the first time i've spoken out
loud i haven't warmed up i'm not a
professional
but all of a sudden i feel like i gotta
sing okay not necessarily
about the muna and the juna and this
brand
but a song that came into my brain and
if i
don't sing it it's gonna just stay in
the head all day
um because sometimes you just
you gotta sing when the spirits sing
you gotta sing when the spirit says sing
when the spirit says sing
you gotta sing right along sing
when the spirits sing i think that's a
wrathy song but that's not the song i
wanna sing i'm not gonna look it up
if you wanna correct me leave comments
below you could be
leave a kind comment with a little bit
of a critique
or even for a man and or a woman for
that matter
i like being single but this song
kind of came to me today and anymore
too much dawn what's that flower
too many people oh okay
delta dawn what's that flower
you have on could it be a
faded rose from days gone by
and did i hear you say you were meeting
him here today
to take you to his mansion in the sky
thank you it's tracy g peace love and
joy
that's all for today
hi welcome and merry meet my friends um
i didn't make up my mattress on the
floor and putty is not
interested in joining us today um
i just i am i'm really me um i really
don't believe in owning a whole lot of
things it goes against
everything i believe in i have a few
electronics mattress on the floor huh
um not even my headset is bluetooth it
still plugs in with two prongs
microphone
and a headphone okay so like i said i
appreciate my easy and
shoes may come out oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] i do not oh [ __ ]
peace hi this is tracy g and this is my
idea of a vision board as you can see it
is not exactly what other people
would do myself as a spiritual person
i do not have a cross at my sacred
vision board because as bill hicks said
would jesus really want to see crosses
when he comes back and i
add to that he'd probably give him ptsd
anyway or his ptsd issues may come out
anyway um this is my image
or my vision board this is what i
envision for myself
and because of my spirituality um
none of it is materialistic really um
anyhow to start off with i have
a pentagram which is the balance of
all of the elements including
earth wind fire and water it
also contains little trinkets and things
that remind me of certain people
and the most important people in my life
are these four
which would include daryl emily my
youngest daughter
she has a jackie eileen my oldest
daughter
she has kids
she has kids
atreyu isaac my youngest grandson
to date and this is 2017
and my oldest grandson which will never
change it's a little shiny because of
the cover that's dustin liam
and those are the four people that are
the most important to me and then i have
trinkets from different people
including those
[Music]
one is from my friend stephanie who has
passed away and that is my seat
i have
a ridiculous collection
just thank you platypus thing because
he's the one that put this up
but that was just 2011 to 2000
man this guy did a great job documenting
this that was 2011 to 2017.
i have
2017-2019 we're not gonna be able
to get through that one today because
again it's very long i'm going to still
play one more thing from her so i'm not
completely
done for today we're going to probably
tomorrow
do the 2017-2019
of her but i still do have one
more and i gotta find it hold on
um this one's a more recent one
here you go
all right this one's called cannabis
commune promo so it's a promo i guess
[Music]
what could be in the store
hello mary
meet bless your heart
it is me reverend tracy g
coming to you to let you know that very
soon
my website will be up and running and
rather than doing
stand-up comedy which you know everybody
thinks they need to sit down for
i am thinking that we ought to just
stick with what i know best tarot
readings
and support sessions and
making a safe place for cannabis medical
marijuana users and
children of ages 18 and over
and others that are supervised by
a responsible adult or at least given
permission to not be censored
i am so excited about this because i am
going to share my ups and downs
the truth about how i'm feeling um i
want to share
um you know make a place that's
welcoming for the mental health the
queer community
medical marijuana patients people with
hyperplasia
hemi hyperplasia um a place
for people with dwarfism um dwarfism
we have dwarf um
the dwarf of my body this is a big
height
part of my body that is small um
it um
well it uh i don't know where i'm going
with that and that's part of it
is losing a train of thought of faith
that is what she looks like a lot of
mixed diagnosis
that happen with people that have heavy
heparin
but i also have borderline personality
disorder no [ __ ] [ __ ]
this so if we quit looking at each
individual system
let me tell you i just found out what
you look like and i think that thank you
adonis because she nailed what she looks
like
you remember and we we watched it
um on the show you remember the female
gremlin
from gremlins 2
because that's what she looks like in
this
the female gremlin from gremlins 2.
just like her
just like her
maybe there might be some cure so i'm
looking forward to my website
um it will be um www
cannabis word.org
and it will be a safe place for people
to come and meet
eventually to have a hotline
for crisis oh my god there's butterflies
for all have wisdom to impart
and at the end of this here greet i
would like to say
blessed be and
peace love
and joy
i
it's what i have to say i am going to
look to
tomorrow we're going to go more into her
obviously we have her 2017-2019 freak
out too
which is look man they're all impressive
honestly
it's not like one's better than the
other but we're really seeing today we
saw the origin
it's like batman begins right um we we
saw the origin of
what basically what happened to her
you know